-Someone --
You know, it obviously hurts m
to say this,
but someone that you have mayb
even better chemistry with
than you have with me
is with Kate Berlant.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-And I'm willing to take
a second position to her.
But what --
You guys just shot a very funny,
very creepy short film calle
"Rachel," based on a true story.
-Yes. Yes.
Yes.
We -- We shot --
We tried to re-create a --
You know, it's actually very
I think --
Hold for the trash truck.
[ Brakes squeal in distance
And we're good.
We -- We shot a --
We shot a very kind of
quarantine-appropriate short
I'm realizing now.
This is pre all of this, though.
But, basically, this
happened to me in real life.
I had friends come over
after a show that I did --
like eight friends for the mos
casual get-together.
And there were a couple
friends of friends there.
Like, people I had
never met before.
So this was kind of already --
it was already --
Subconsciously, I was alread
accepting the fact
that I wouldn't know
some people there.
And this girl -- Literally as
was letting people into my home,
this girl ran up my steps
so boldly
and just so casually and boldly.
And she's like, "I have to pee."
And I was like, "Oh, okay.
And I just --
I just assumed
because of her boldness,
I was like,
"Well, she must know someone."
And then, she literally spen
an hour, two hours in my house
Just like -- again,
a party of like eight people
This was not a raver.
She was not invisible.
She was like --
She took her shoes off.
After she went to the bathroom
took her shoes off,
curled up on my couch and
started talking to my friend
It was like -- she literally -
And this is in the short.
She was like, "Are you
a dancer?" to my friend.
My friend was like, "No."
She was like, "You're a dancer."
And they like -- And then,
they have this conversation.
Because they were talking
for so long, we just were like
"I guess they know each other,
you know?
At one point, my friend looked
over the couch at me
and was like, "Do you know her?"
I was like, "No."
But I said it in a joking wa
so she thought --
she thought I was kidding.
And then --
And then slowly, we all starte
to connect the dots.
We were kind of drunk,
and I started pulling people
back in the kitchen
and being like --
and grilling people, being like,
"Do you know her?"
And people were like,
"No, I do not."
And we all, like,
slowly put it together
that no one in the house
knew who she was.
And then,
we had to kick her out.
And I like --
I have never --
I am so afraid of confrontation.
-That's --
The scariest part, by far,
is not be having a strange
in my house, it would be
having to confront the strange
and possibly be framed
as a rude person.
-[ Laughs ]
Exactly.
By the way, by a total strange
who intruded in my house.
I'm worried about
what she thinks of me.
Which is absolutely --
So my friend just kind of
took over for me and, like
you know, kicked her out.
And she was so defensive.
She was like --
She was treating us
like we were nerds
for not kind of letting
a stranger in.
-Great.
-And, yeah, it was --
it was so horrifying
and, truly, did not leave
my system for weeks.
It was so creepy.
-Yeah.
-We just tried to re-create it
as like accurately as possible
in the short film.
-So it was like an
"Unsolved Mysteries" re-creation
of Rachel's intrusion
into your home.
-Exactly.
-I feel like my wife
would let her stay only becaus
she took her shoes off.
-It's like the
Duplass version of herself
-Oh. Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Sorry, but keep --
Back to your wife.
You always bring up your wife --
-She would let Rachel stay
'cause she took her shoes off,
which is something that
she would say, like,
"This person may not be invited,
but at least they had the
decency as a guest
to remove their shoes
in my home."
-Yeah.